we're going to turn now to North Korea
and some wild new claims about the
country's military capabilities the
government there released images
supposedly showing a new underwater
nuclear device that the leadership says
could create get this what it calls a
radioactive tsunami all becomes amid
renewed military exercises between the
U.S and South Korea and our Liz Palmer
has more on all of it
in a still photograph North Korea's
dictator Kim Jong-un is sitting in front
of what the official news service says
was a new underwater drone other photos
purport to show it at Sea where North
Korea claimed it had cruised for 59
hours before detonating armed with a
nuclear warhead North Korea said it
could cause a radioactive tsunami
that could be used to attack enemy Naval
units or ports
Kim Jong-un also apparently watched
Conventional Weapons tests too cruise
missiles being moved on mobile launchers
and then being fired into the ocean
North Korea claims these can carry
nuclear warheads too though military
analysts are skeptical it has the
technology at least yet
this most recent flaunting of Weaponry
which last week included a submarine
launched missile is a response to U.S
South Korean military exercises
Freedom Shield which ended yesterday is
the biggest joint exercise in five years
and included live fire tank Maneuvers
and an amphibious Landing
a furious North Korea denounced the
exercise which it views as a rehearsal
for an invasion for CBS mornings
Elizabeth Palmer Tokyo